make way for Notah Begay golf channel
coverage and also with NBC coverage over
the weekend with the Arnold Palmer three
of the top 20 players in the world will
be scheduled to play in the World Golf
Championships that'll be the Dell
Technology Match Play brackets that will
be a special on Monday March 19th on the
Golf Channel the show features special
guests with the selection process
including Roger Clemens and Luke Wilson
so no to be part of Golf Channel and
NBC's tournament coverage this week
Notah thanks for joining us how was this
past weekend spending it with Tiger it
was great
I mean the second consecutive week that
he's really factored in the event and it
just energized our game it just
energized the people that went out to
watch it was it was truly sort of a
rejuvenation of what it was like to have
Tiger in contention again golf
tournament is has he ever asked you to
be honest with him with what you see I
try and be honest as honest as I can I
mean I've been friends with him over
thirty years I know it's golf swing it
so I'm not the one that's going to
interject anything that's unsolicited
but if he asked me I'll be honest and
sometimes it's not the entries looking
for but but you know in terms of certain
elements of his game I mean I was in a
lot of conversations with him and Earl
at a lot of dinners you know his first
Masters it was myself and Earl and Tiger
we all travel together from a drove down
from Atlanta and so I've seen all the
good and all the bad and any and
everything in between so it's it's it
covers a sort of a broad spectrum of
issues at times but we've had a really
great friendship what's the one concern
the biggest concern because I don't
think he's playing until Augusta so what
would be the one thing you think he's
working on well project number one over
the next two weeks is going to be the
driver I think there's two things that
you would have to look at with regard to
watching them playing it doesn't show up
on
the statistics because you have to
actually be out there and watch but
anytime that he had to turn a shot right
to left with trouble with trouble on the
left he struggled a little bit off 260
off the ninety there was some errant
shots and then we saw the really
horrible tee shot yesterday at 16 where
he just talked about it in his post
round comment he just didn't commit to a
shot and the worst thing that a
professional athlete can do to
themselves to compromise performance is
not commit and so he made a terrible
swing and that's the Miss that is really
difficult for him to recover from
because get the majority of his misses
are out to the right so so when you when
you eliminate one half of a golf course
you can really make your way around
realm around a golf a lot easier but
when you have a two-way miss going which
sometimes creeps into his driver it
really makes it difficult to sort of
take out some of the trouble that you're
looking at when you're standing on the
tee box so he has to sort of really
focus in on trying to find some way to
navigate Augusta National with the
driver because it's of course it's gonna
force you to hit driver who should be
the favorite and Augusta right now I
think it should be Rory I mean I I think
the only thing going against Rory is no
player has ever made the has has
completed the career Grand Slam at
Augusta National so he's got history
working against him but his ability to
hit his driver so if you look at the two
players Tiger Woods sort of versus Rory
McIlroy right now the weakest Club in
Tigers bag is his driver the strongest
Club in Rory's bag is his driver and you
you go down to the other end of the
spectrum Tiger is phenomenal around the
Greens he was second in the strokes
gained around the green category this
week at Bay Hill and Rory often has you
know he's not bad at all but just is not
as prolific in that particular area of
the game so it just kind of it's an
either-or discussion you know if you
want guy that can drive it far hitches
straight and is not afraid to hit it on
the biggest
stages and you got to go with Rory but
if you want a guy that's won it four
times and can go around that golf course
blindfolded then you gotta go with Tiger
Woods Rory said that they should limit
alcohol sales had a fan heckling him
mentioning Rory's wife you're there
you're a professional golfer you were
there with tiger you know how chaotic it
can get I mean how how ugly how personal
does it get with this with the fans well
I I think it's um it's a little bit of a
concern and I think it's it comes down
to Dan you know where we categorize us
ourselves as a sport I saw some pretty
ugly behavior at the 2016 Ryder Cup at
Hazeltine a lot of the American fans
were kind of diggin into the European
side which well I have nothing against
tackling I've got nothing against sort
of cheer rooting for your team but when
you cross the line it gets personal I
think that's kind of a little bit
overboard and I think that what has to
happen is the PGA Tour and the governing
bodies of our sport need to do a better
job just observing and maintaining a
secure workspace for the golfers because
you there's there's no assigned seats so
it's very easy for someone to cause an
issue like we saw what Justin Thomas at
Honda we saw yesterday with Rory and
with Tiger coming back and so many
people want to come back there is gonna
be some negative cheering out there
against some of the other players which
is probably what Rory was experiencing
but I can tell you I heard a couple
crazy things come out of people's mouths
right right as Tiger was swinging and I
tried to look around to see who it was
and I couldn't find him so it's just a
hard thing the police but it's something
I think the tour needs to monitor and
sort of keep their eye on wait what did
you hear well you know the tip the
typical bababooey mashed potatoes let's
go Tiger I mean somebody that's just
trying to get their voice on TV and it's
in you know after the ball is gone
that's fine but like they were doing it
right at the top of this swing and you
know he's so focused and majority of
these athletes don't even hear this
stuff but it's one of those things to
wear
that's not hasn't been historically a
part of our sport where basketball and
football I mean it's commonplace but
it's just kind of I don't know if we
have to get kind of get used to the
modern age of golf or there has to be a
little bit more policing as far as
keeping the fans at least a little bit
more reasonable in there cheering who
would be the golfer you would send into
the gallery to clean up things he'd be
your number one seed wow that's a great
question you know I would have to go
back back into the the archives a little
bit and I'd bring full-time alum out of
the locker room it was a scary dude man
that's a kid and will think I'm mad you
stayed out of the way but right now sort
of modern day and I don't know if
there's any connection here it'd be
another South African I bring big Ernie
out you the international team captain
he's a huge man and he's a very imposing
figure and I think if he went into the
gallery now something to sort of keep
their mouths shut I would probably
assume they would listen to him you
wouldn't send tiger in there no no he's
a diplomat we need someone in there how
many times did you beat Tiger Woods in
your career in it in actual golf
tournament um probably a dozen times I
mean when our first semester at Stanford
I was the number one player on the golf
team which many people don't believe and
which is it's true I've got a whole list
of teammates to back me up but he took
it over a second semester sort of never
looked back but which is how I know the
crowd that he attracts can somehow you
know can sometimes throw other players
off because when we're playing our
collegiate events it was the only time
when we'd have a couple thousand people
coming out to watch college golf when
typically if you had more than 50 people
that was a big big crowd and they they
teed him off your your fifth player teed
off first and then you work back through
the lineup and the number one guy would
go off last so Tiger was the number two
guy
so he would go off before me and I got
through about you know 2/3 of the way
through the season I'm like coach I
can't play behind him because there's
people walking in the fairway there's
people walking on the green they're you
know going to take a leak in the trees I
mean it's just kind of like I guess can
you put me in front of them and just put
it behind me but he took care of that
could he took over the number one spot
and I didn't have to worry about that
the rest of season but it can be it not
I shouldn't say it it is a distraction
I mean bud collie got a first hand yeah
yes but I haven't seen it that energized
when he made that putt on the 13th hole
to get I think within one of the lead I
mean the crowd was they were just going
nuts and it was fun to be there it was
fun to be you know 15 feet away from
when we made that putt I was on the call
and it was just quite a sort of
interesting experience I was listening
to a podcast Hank Haney's podcast and he
had Jaime Diaz the golf writer and he
said that what Tiger went through when
Tiger was pulled over he thinks that was
a call for help what do you make of that
comment well I think that anytime an
athlete or an individual is dealing with
those sorts of battles with medication
alcohol whatever it is at some point
yeah there is there is a bottom where
everybody bottoms out and however you
want to characterize it depending on
which self-help book you read you'll get
a variety of different opinions but I
think the two most important things that
came out of that is number one he did
hurt himself or anybody else which i
think is critical and secondly he's
gotten better because of it he has
changed his lifestyle he's changed the
way he's approached things and he has
come out a better person because of
those experiences and I think that in
you know today's society where a lot of
these athletes are just are living
everything publicly through social media
everybody has a voice it's just good to
see him sort of recover and
way that he did and he you know he went
and sought out professional help which i
think is the best thing to do because I
know there's a lot of things to unravel
and he's done a good job of finding some
firm footing
he's relied on some great resources and
you know whether you want to
characterize it as a call for help or
just bottoming out it kind of depends on
like I said who you talk to
well sent well put Noda thank you we
appreciate the time and perhaps we'll
see you down the road thank you
absolutely that's Notah Begay golf
channel analyst NBC sports on course
reporter following Tiger Woods for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]